jeanette bogue is an assistant professor
of computer science for robotics here at
stanford she directs the interactive
perception and robot learning lab
let me just
uh and her research is focused on
robotic grasping and manipulation she
has received several early career and
best paper awards most notably the 2019
ieee i think that's the way you say it
robotics and automation society early
career award and the 2020 robotics
science and systems early career award
it's always really interesting uh
talking to her and we have a link below
to another discussion he did with her
and two other roboticists here at
stanford uh because i hear so much about
we all hear so much about the incredible
advances in artificial intelligence and
computers um
and incredible complex problems they're
solving and then you talk to roboticists
and you find out that there's still some
very basic things that are a challenge
for robots in particular manipulating
and grabbing and moving basic everyday
objects and so this is a big part of
what what jeanette's research focuses on
and we'll she'll be talking today about
how her successes in this field and her
failures have informed her approach to
this topic and her thinking about the
future of it
and so with that i'm excited to hand it
over to jeanette uh two quick one other
quick notes just a reminder we will have
a q a at the end so please submit those
questions in the q a box uh jeanette
will be also sharing her screen so your
media player may expand you can resize
it and she will be sharing a few videos
and it's unfortunately just the nature
of our platform that those videos will
be a little bit choppy it's not anything
on your end or anything we can
troubleshoot on our end uh but you
should still be able to see the basic
robotic uh motion and and jeannette will
be able to get her basic points across
but that's just a note for you so with
that uh janette i'm going to
hand uh hand the the reigns over
to you
thank you very much pax for the really
nice introduction and for kind of giving
a preview of what i'm going to talk
about so let me just quickly share my
screen
so i hope everyone is going to see that
so today i really want to talk about
what i've learned from my successes and
failures and my work
and how that informs my current research
research and what i think is important
in robotic grasping and manipulation
um
so i really uncovered some principles uh
there that i think will bring us closer
to autonomous robots um yeah so with
that i just want to mention again my
research is on robotic manipulation and
grasping and it's really driven by the
puzzle
of why humans can effortlessly
manipulate any kind of object
while it is really hard to reproduce
this skill on a robot that has a
completely different embodiment from a
person
and so in my first phd research work
that i've done
kind of starting 2008 and then published
in this paper in 2010 i tried to address
this particular challenge by looking
into finding suitable grasping points
for any kind of object
and we assume that these objects are
presented to the robot as 2d images and
it's supposed to kind of find these
points in these images
and so we formalized this problem
of grass point detection and images as a
classification problem as put forward by
saxena at all in 2006.
so imagine you have this robot who wants
to pick up this cup from the table
and it sees this cap through a camera
and we compute a per pixel feature
and compute the probability that this
pixel represents a good grasping point
so y equals one here means good grasping
point
and how do we train the simple
classifier um we use the same database
that was put forward by succeeding at
all and use supervised learning to train
in this case an svm remember this was
2006 pre-deep learning
okay so the contribution that i made in
my particular work
was on the feature representation i
propose to use something called shape
context that captures the shape of an
entire object relative to a pixel in
that particular image
so
really here is how this
looks like
and specifically we have this particular
histogram feature here
and we showed that this really
indeed outperforms the previous feature
formulation by a large margin for many
different objects
okay so this is really just a
quick
walkthrough through that method and so
now
given this feature of representation we
have an idea what pixel in the rgb image
of this cup here for example represents
a good grasping point um but of course
grasping is a spatial process
a 3d process really and we need to infer
an orientation and a position of the
hand
that is somehow linked to that 2d
grasping point
and the details here are not very
important
but we basically use local 3d
information around that 2d grasping
point we detected in the image
to infer eventually like a really a hand
pose
for the robot
um okay so here are
uh two examples of this work of this
method that i just talked about in
action uh and in both of these videos
there's the robot is going to
successfully grasp an object so this is
quite a vintage video remember this is
in 2009
so here the robot that i use with this
three-fingered hand is basically going
to
grasp
this particular box um
[Music]
and we'll be successfully lifting it
and uh the second video here it's also
going to be success the robot is also
going to be successfully grasping but
maybe also pay attention to the shadows
here in the background
so i hope you see that despite the video
being a bit choppy this was me
uh
basically
an absolute joy that this actually
worked and so you can infer from how
happy i i am back in 2009 that does
actually work that this method actually
was really hard to make work and that
that it didn't necessarily work that
often
and so here i also want to share with
you a few failures um this first one
here for example is more of an i would
say an accidental grasp the this object
the spray bottle eventually ends up in
the hand but it's really more like a
coincidence
and the second one um you see this is
maybe a little hard to see due to the
quality of the video but there's a cup
on this table
and the robot tries to grasp it and it's
gonna slip off the rim of the cup and so
you see it could actually really need
some tactile feedback to understand that
this is actually not gonna work
okay so what are the insights
that i gained
from this project
so the work the earlier work that i
based my work on by saxena has certainly
kick-started the entire field of
learning to grasp for robots
and it departed from prior work that
made many many assumptions about what is
known about the object
it also did not
infer
precise
contact points but
only hand poses
and today we actually find many
interesting works that basically follow
this overall approach um like here for
example the google iron farm or dexnet
by
ken goldberg's lab
so these approaches have basically
nowadays better data better learning
approaches and so on
and if you want to know more about these
you can look at these surveys one
written by myself in 2012 and the newer
one in 2019.
um so i made contributions uh to this
field uh throughout the years but
this first approach that i just showed
you was actually extremely brittle and
failed often
and here's what i learned so 2d grasping
points
really do not carry enough information
to be successful in grasping they still
have to be transformed to a
three-dimensional hand pose so a
position and an orientation of the hand
and this conversion can be very brittle
also open loop control of the robot arm
does not work so not taking any for
example tactile feedback in an account
to determine if things are actually
going well does not work
and also the
approach that i showed you completely
ignores the environmental context and
requires careful post-processing of any
movement of the robot for collision
checking and so on
so um
[Music]
so for me personally the real value of
this first ever this first phd project
that i've done was not
actually in the scientific contributions
although there was one but the real
value for me personally was in the
lesson i learned on what works and
especially and what does not work in
robotic grasping
um so the first thing uh i learned is
that uh grasp representation really
matter and
matter a lot and they should be spatial
so three-dimensional
uh continuous multimodal feedback and
constant replanning is crucial in
robotic manipulation and maybe to many
of your work with robots this may be
obvious but it wasn't
obvious for me back in 2009
and it's not necessarily obvious on how
to actually do it
in real time
and then
a last point
instead of avoiding collision with
everything else but the target object
it really helps the robot and also us as
people if we exploit contact with the
environment and i will explain a little
bit more later on what i mean but uh
let's first start with the first point
so how do we get spatial grasp
representation of instead of just like
one point in the image
so let's get rid of this 2d grasping
point
detected in rgb images that this prior
work has done
so
and the reason why we want that is uh
because a good grasp actually uh depends
on both
the shape and the form of the object but
also on the capabilities and kinematics
of the gripper
and so
in my lab we proposed a method called
unigrasp for grasping any object
with any gripper
and so to achieve this unigraph selects
sets of contact points
and
as input it takes the object point cloud
uh recorded with some
you know 3d camera and a specification
of the kinematics and geometry of the
robot hand and then this model unigrasp
sequentially outputs contact points and
these contact points are both reachable
by the hand
basically contact points of each of the
fingers and they are also in something
called force closure which you can just
think about uh a grasp actually being
stable
and uh the hand being able to balance uh
the object in hand without dropping it
so unigras is able to extract gripper
geometry and kinematic features and
concatenate them with object features in
this encoding stage in the first stage
of this model and i will explain this
model first
so we use uh something called a udf file
of the gripper so it's basically a
description of the kinematics and
geometry of a robotic hand or of a robot
in general
and using this description we generate a
point cloud of the gripper in a
particular joint configuration
and we use these point clouds as input
to train
an auto encoder to learn a low
dimensional
feature representation
that encodes the geometry of the robotic
hands in specific joint configuration
and we yeah we then use the encoder to
compute features in different um with
different hand configurations so for
example different openings
and concatenate them
and so this here what you see here is a
visualization of the embedding space so
you first compute
the features of two input point clouds
here on the left and on the right and
circle them red
and we interpolate these two features
and decode these interpolated features
into grip of point clouds
that you actually see here in the middle
you can see that the top row
uh shows a prismatic joint movement so
basically an opening and closing of the
fingers
and the middle row represents a revolute
joint movement so basically you're
changing the angle
and the bottom row shows the geometry
changes between two types of different
3d finger robotic hands
so
what the slide basically shows is that
this latent space that represents
gripper geometry and kinematics has
can be meaningfully interpolated and
also generalized over different hands
okay so in addition to the gripper
feature that i just showed you
we also extract an object feature using
a point model called pointnet plus plus
and concatenate it with the gripper
feature
and then the concatenated feature will
be fed into a point set selection
network to sequentially output
contact points for the robotic hand
and so we we propose a new model for
solving the difficult combinatorical
problem of finding a set of contact
points among the object point clouds and
i don't have time to explain uh this
very complex model here
but i just gonna walk you through a more
abstract representation of this model
so
given an n
gripper
the network has n stages so in stage 1
the model estimates the probability for
each point in the object point cloud if
the point
belongs to a valid set of contact points
and after ranking these points the model
selects the top k points that are shown
here in blue
and then conditioned on one of these
points
one of these blue points selected in the
first stage the model now predicts the
probability of each point in the point
cloud to form a valid set of contacts
with the first
point and these points are then ranked
again and the top k points are selected
and then finally in stage three we
select the third contact point for the
three-fingered hand here in this case
conditioned on the first two contact
points
and so the network is trained to output
points that are in force closure so
produce a stable grasp and are also
reachable by the hand in the first place
and before executing the graph we still
can check kinematic visibility for the
hand
okay so here is how this actually looks
like for a toy example to visualize how
our model predicts reasonable contact
points that are dependent on the gripper
geometry
and of the kinematics as well so in
black gear you see the object
and in blue the gripper
and the first gripper has
a very small opening of the two fingers
so the model
our model unigras generates contact
points at the thin part of the object
and
here the second hand
this one
has the same shape but it cannot fully
close the fingers
but instead it can open very widely so
the model outputs contact points that
are on a thicker
part of the object
and finally for a three-fingered hand
the model also again outputs reasonable
contact points for each of these
painters
so we used our model unigrasp to grasp
objects shown in the middle here with
five different
uh robotic hands that you see here at
the bottom that are really quite
different
and
here i want to show you a bunch of
videos that i hope are uh okay visible
to you
so we basically test our model by
grasping novel objects that
this model hasn't been trained on with a
known gripper and here in non-gripper
means that we have trained our model
with that gripper
we test when using the this what is
called the robotique 3f gripper and our
model achieves 95 success rate on these
65 trials that we have done on real
hardware
and but even more interesting with this
model something that no other model has
actually done is
to we wanted to see if we can grasp
objects novel objects with novel grip
grippers that the model has been trained
on
so
here you we see a
new robotic hands
or by
actually it's a hand uh
that we have trained our model on except
we have removed in our description file
one of the fingers so it's now only a
two-fingered gripper and our model
achieves 93 grass success rate on 60
trials which is really good
and here is a very interesting
anthropomorphic hand with four fingers
um and uh it's called the allegro hand
and our model achieves 90 success rate
um
why our baseline method achieves only 40
percent
and of course um there are some failure
cases as well and these are typically
due to imprecise perception
low frictions or slippery objects object
deformations and premature contact with
with the object
and so uh just to summarize this
particular work uh the main idea is here
that
that we can feed a model with a
object and a hand description something
that hasn't been previously done to
compute contact points for the fingers
instead of like one 2d grasping point
and the algorithmic contribution here
was a point set selection network that i
really briefly explained
and um the result is a model that
outputs a violet grasp also for novel
robotic hands which is really relevant
for
for example if you think in
manufacturing when a robot gets a new
hand right you may not want to retrain
your model
okay so
this was
giving you an idea of how we've removed
that one ascension from this old model
to make it basically better and
in terms of introducing a spatial grasp
representation
and
i want to come to the next point which
is
um the importance of continuous feedback
during actually executing a grasp and
the ability to replan
so uh
what
i don't know for those of you who have
worked with robots it's probably
relatively clear
that you have to
close something called the perception
action loop around
high dimensional sensory data that comes
for example from cameras or from tactile
sensors
so it means that basically the robot
should be able to continuously take
feedback into account and react to it
but how to do that concretely on a
high-dimensional system is an open
question
and so
i started focusing directly on this time
on this point uh using this particular
robot so here's an example for some
behavior that the resulting system
that we built produces um
and
you see um here that uh this robot is
called apollo it has to grasp the
sprinkles box without knocking anything
over
and uh my colleague here jim maine price
he makes it really hard for apollo by
moving around these objects in the
environment and it has to react in
millisecond
apollo the robot has to keep track of
the environment in real time and provide
the feedback to a fast motion generation
mechanism that drives the behavior and
allows it to react
so it's this is really a system where
real time perception meets reactive
motion generation
and so here is a very simplified figure
of how the architecture of such a system
of a robotic system that is operating
under the hood actually looks like
and i have no time to explain each box
but each of them makes a contribution to
either robust real-time
visual robot arm or object tracking or
online trajectory generation
what i want you to pay attention to is
how these real-time perception methods
and reactive motion generation methods
are actually connected and so in our
system everything is connected in loops
of different frequencies where sensory
data feeds into
controllers or motion optimization
methods
um
also um all of these things come at
different
rates so the camera runs at 30 hertz the
haptic sensor runs at kilohertz so all
of this has to be processed
asynchronously and notice that this is
not a hierarchy or something it's really
a bunch of loops
so it's important
one thing important to note is that it
doesn't matter
how amazing each of these components are
if you put them together in the wrong
way your system will not work well and
in this paper we showed exactly this in
empirically
so let me walk you through one loop
in the system so we start with raw
sensory data
that what you see is basically a point
cloud
from the top and what you don't really
see here is that there's also some
haptic data and feedback on where the
joints of the robot currently are
um so rgb and depth data come in at 30
hertz and proprioceptive data from the
robot at a kilohertz
so and then using real-time visual
tracking methods this data is processed
to infer the object pose the robot iron
posts and obstacles in the environment
that you see here in these kind of
rainbow colored little voxels
and given this information we compute a
potential field where the target object
provides an attractive potential
and the obstacles um
basically
provide a repulsive potential as shown
here with the red arrows
so this feedback is used by local
controllers that compute the optimal
action that bring the arm closer to the
object to the target object and push it
away from the obstacles
and then we also use online trajectory
optimizers that optimize actions over a
time horizon of two seconds
and produce what we call acceleration
policies so in this case it's called
romanian motion policies
that are tracked with
some low-level controller
and this online trajectory optimizes
much slower than the uh very
basic feedback controllers and therefore
cannot react as quickly to changes
but it's certainly less susceptible to
local minimum and we refuse these two
types of policies to obtain a fuse
policy that is updated at a kilohertz
and that you see here
in yellow
okay so in this paper we compare three
system architectures we have a standard
sense plan architecture that senses
first then plans and then acts without
taking feedback into account
and then we have a reactive architecture
that does not look ahead
for computing the next best action but
runs extremely fast at the kilohertz and
we have the proposed architecture that
runs a number of loops asynchronously
including an online planner that looks
ahead for optimizing the next action
and so we evaluated these different
system architectures that all consist of
the same components
in four different scenarios
and i can only
in the interest of time only show you
this one example
and so
here what you see is just an overview of
the setup um
the robot basically has to again
pick and place this
box here this cylindrical chips
box
pick it up and bring it to the other
side of the table on the right and what
happens here specifically is that this
cardboard box is being pushed in the way
and
yeah basically the robot has to avoid it
and at the bottom right corner you see
what the robot sees so these kind of
voxels and you know the colorful voxels
down there
is what the robot basically has
available as information
okay so here first is this sense plan
act architecture that basically senses
once plans wants and then executes
and it doesn't take feedback into
account so it doesn't realize there's a
box in a way so just gonna basically
collide with it right and we'll just go
through this of course is okay in this
scenario because the box is light
but of course you want to definitely
avoid that
and so here in the middle we have the
system that uses a reactive controller
and you see that it manages to
uh
not really collide as
with this box
but it also cannot really find a way to
get to the other side although there is
right and it does recover uh once the
box is removed but it's basically stuck
in a local minima
and so the
proposed method uh can cope with this
um so even though the box gets in the
way it is able to look ahead uh in time
and find uh this narrow passage between
the box and its own body to go to get
the box to the other side um so this
combination of a
long horizon trajectory optimizer with
um
a fast local controller is really the
best option that we have here
okay so just to summarize this
particular part of the talk
we the main idea of this of this work
was
that system architectures really have to
consist of these interlocked perception
action loops that
connect
sensory feedback with motion controllers
and then the contribution that we made
here was that we really evaluated
the influence of system architecture on
performance
of the system
and the result was a system that can
perform successfully manipulate objects
in uncertain and dynamic environments
all right so
with that i want to come
so that part i basically emphasized how
important it is that a robot is able to
take continuously feedback into account
and be able to replan
and
the last point that i took away from my
initial phd work was that
a robot really benefits from actually
exploiting the environment rather than
only avoiding it
so let me explain
what that means so it turns out that
humans are actually
not uh
avoiding the environment when
manipulating objects which is something
that we always try robots
try to make robots do or in for example
autonomous driving it's very important
to avoid the environment right but in
manipulation it's actually detrimental
so here is an
example from julia child chopping
potatoes that was introduced to the
community by this professor matt mason
from cmu and for example you see how
she's using her knuckles as a constraint
to guide the knife
and this is just one of the things that
she does to exploit the environment
and so there are other examples of smart
design so for example this atm here
they often this has this funnel around
the card slot to make it easier for
people to insert the card
and so
autonomously learning robot skills any
kind of manipulation skills is really
challenging as you see here so these are
examples of very contact-rich tasks like
peg insertion or a wrench task or
inserting a battery into a phone at the
very right and they require quite some
accuracy and have a very small margin of
error
and in fact um
there are many examples where it has
shown that getting in touch with the
environment instead of
and exploiting it um
makes grasping more robust so here's an
example for packing session that is
really hard but when we put this kind of
bracket there this fixture as we call it
in red suddenly this becomes easy
because the fixture it blocks the wrong
motion
of the robot it really acts like a
funnel
that restricts the motion of the robot
and guides the robot towards a
successful goal
um so other people have also recognized
this um that
these environmental constraints can be
exploited here are some examples
however the majority of these of the
works in this area they are often design
how the environment can be exploited and
thereby determine the behavior ahead of
time
and what we've wondered in our work is
that if a robot can discover how to best
place these kinds of fixtures itself
so this is really the question
we asked in this work
can a robot autonomously discover how to
ease manipulation skill learning
problems through the optimal placement
of such a picture of the red fixture
that you've seen
in this video before
so our approach consists of an inner and
an outer loop that each run
reinforcement learning
and so the outer loop
learns to place a physical fixture
um that you that you see here so um you
see like this blue robot has this red
fixture in the hand and it tries to
learn how to place it best so that the
other robot can do the insertion task
so the inner loop learns the
manipulation skill
given this fixture pose and after a
fixed number of iterations this inner
loop returns the achieved reward
to the outer loop and so the higher the
reward achieved by the inner loop the
more reward the fixture pose receives in
the outer loop
so
we formulate this outer loop problem as
a contextual bandit problem and the goal
is to learn a good policy for choosing
an action
given the context and the context here
is really a depth image of this
manipulation test of the object that is
being
manipulated
so in the outer loop we are learning a
qw
that approximates the true q function
which outputs the expected reward after
taking an action a and the context is
the depth image
here
represented by this gray image and is
processed by cnn
and
so and
so basically the the action is uh
placing this fixture and in black here
and the state is this sf
and uh at test time we use an algorithm
called qt up uh to find an optimal
action so we take this qw
and we find the maximum the action af
that maximizes the expected reward and
that's basically our
policy
so there's like a particular challenge
here in learning this qw
that approximates the true q function
and the
and
that is that the true q function is
actually discontinuous so let me explain
so uh for training um so basically you
have here um
on the
y-axis the expected reward so you want
that to be high
for particular good actions and on the
x-axis you have particular options for a
fixture pose
and
you see that on the very
left uh the fixture this uh black
bracket is basically covering the hole
and of course that means that the other
robot cannot even insert uh anything
into that hole
so that should give very low reward
and then as soon as you perfectly align
the bracket with that hole as you see in
this middle option suddenly the expected
reward is really high
and then the further we remove it the
reward kind of gracefully degrades but
the problem is there's this
discontinuity there
so for training we proposed a new smooth
zooming algorithm that we showed capable
of learning this discontinuous function
and i'm not going to go into detail this
feel free to look at the paper if you're
interested
so for the inner loop i also mentioned
that we use
reinforcement learning but there we use
model free rl
that learns a good policy for this
specific task given a particular bracket
and so what we found is that learning is
really significantly faster
with a good fixture placement
with a good fixed replacement so here
what you see is that
um you see basically the success rate
on the top
given different conditions so if we have
an optimal fixed replacement in orange
the success rate becomes really fast uh
really high
and if we have a sub-optimal fixture
placement
in purple
the robot has a really hard time
actually learning it and without a
fixture it takes even longer
so
[Music]
i think what is happening here is that
this particular red fixture there is
really constraining the action space
that doesn't have to be explored
so it makes learning really faster and
for the other tasks we explored in this
paper the picture is kind of similar
okay so
putting it all together
one thing to remember here is basically
the faster the inner loop robot learns
how to do the peg insertion task in this
particular case the higher is the reward
for the outer loop robot and so it
notices
which
fixture placement is actually the best
and here's a visualization of this qw
function for fixture post selection and
maybe i don't go into detail of this one
but it basically learns something
meaningful
and so here is uh here's an example of
how this actually looks like on a real
robot
so first the robot is basically trying
to figure out like okay which one of
these placements of the fixture gives me
the highest expected reward and once it
found it
um the the other robot is basically
doing the manipulation task giving this
pose and you saw that it was really fast
at doing that and here was another test
revenge test you also saw the other
robot was holding the red block finding
a good position to support the second
robot to do the actual wrench task
and here is the task of
it's called shallow depth insertion it's
basically how to automatically insert a
battery into your phone
and you see that um
this is quite a complex manipulation for
the robot holding the the battery the
yellow part and so a correct fixed
replacement is really making it easier
for it
and one cool thing
about this approach is that
we actually trained all of this in
simulation and then we directly test the
resulting policy in the real world and
additionally
because of this physical fixture the
learned policy also generalizes to new
pac shape and the robot doesn't even
know that these have different shapes
but the fixed replacement is just
kind of generalizing to these different
shapes
yeah so just to summarize this
particular
part
the main idea of this of this research
project was to learn to let a robot
learn how to alter the environment
to help scaffold
manipulation learning for another robot
to help it to learn faster
and we made an algorithmic contribution
that i didn't explain much in detail
here but the result was more robust
manipulation and learning is sped up
dramatically uh once you find the right
fixed replacement
okay so with this i want to conclude my
talk and i showed you some results from
my first project i have done during my
phd and i gave you three lessons that i
personally took away from observing the
limitations of this first work
and i showed you three works that
address these challenges
so first i showed you some work that and
first contact points instead of
instead of these 2d grasping points
and
that work allowed you to infer really a
spatial grasping pose of the hand and
even with novel hands
and i showed you a
concrete example for a system
architecture that consists of interlock
perception action loops
and can deal with dynamic dynamically
changing an uncertain environments
by allowing continuous feedback and
replanning and finally i also showed you
work in which a robot can learn to alter
the environment to scaffold manipulation
and where the robot holding this yellow
part you can really exploit the
environment to do more robust
manipulation
okay so yeah so after all of these works
of course we are looking at
uh
more interesting research questions like
for example how can we include more
sensing modalities like vision touch
motion
language and
even sound
and we are looking at more difficult
manipulation tasks so for example long
horizon tasks or manipulating deformable
objects like rope and
laundry and we're also looking at how
multiple robots can actually coordinate
with each other in a good way for
example for
conveyor belt operations or multi-drone
delivery systems
and with that i thank you very much for
your attention
and i thank of course all my students
and
my funding sources for providing the
means to do this research thank you very
much
thank you jeanette that was wonderful
and
really appreciated that and uh and we
have a lot of great questions
so with that i i want to jump into the q
a and we have um
so jeanette we have kind of an
interesting mix of both very specific
and some general questions so i thought
i'd start maybe with a general one that
builds off your last uh your last point
around how robots are using can use and
create environmental constraints to
scaffold the learning for another robot
and so
what do you this is kind of a big
question so in terms of the built
environment how do you see it changing
in order to accommodate robots or or
will robots continue to sort of learn to
work within the human built environment
one example that i came across when
preparing for this was that apparently
bricklaying is very hard for robots to
do and one of the reasons is bricks are
kind of built for being manipulated by
people and not robots so where do you
see the future of of kind of built-in
environmental constraints aiding robots
versus humans and and that whole i guess
it's a very big question but i care
about your thoughts
yeah it's it's a very very good question
so in fact um yeah there are kind of
like two
current facts on on this i guess so
first of all
robots are
very incapable in unstructured
environments at the moment right it's
very hard to make them work so what
where robots are currently working
really well are environments that are
actually built for them in a way right
and
so in factories where assembly lines are
basically met like basically what robots
are working on on assembly lines they
are typically structured for them so
that they have an easier time
manipulating and where uncertainty is
also reduced as much as possible
and so
i think uh
it's basically
a requirement right now to design the
environment such that a robot works
reasonably well
and so what what we really uh so the
second that's one fact of the current
kind of state of things and the second
one is that um people are
also exploiting environmental
constraints and in fact there are really
good designs of products and of the home
or of just everyday environments that
make it easy for people to manipulate
them just like this one example i had
like right with the atm for example
but just think of doorknobs and of of
door handles and you know your stove and
how they are designed right they're all
made somewhere for people and um so i
think it's it's very viable to also
consider designing the environment um
for robots to make it easier for them
but also maybe to change the hardware of
robots to make it easier for them to
manipulate things that are already in
our environment
um
and in our work we were really
interested in
if the environment is maybe not as
friendly to a robot right now how can a
robot
basically change it autonomously to help
itself or maybe help another robot and
so
this work that i showed is really just
the beginning of it and it still
has there the robot only has very few
choices of what to actually do and it
can't really pick the shape of the
environmental constraints for example we
give it one shape
and so they're really interesting
questions there that
to explore and how to expand this um
towards this vision that i just outlined
that a robot can actually help itself to
manipulate better so if you want to work
on that idea you should come to the
chorus and explore that research project
that's fantastic yeah that's that's very
interesting um we have a couple other i
don't know if this is a good segue but
the question just popped up um is
and this is again maybe a high level uh
question
have there been biologically inspired um
solutions for object grasping are they
and i so i don't know quite how we would
interpret that whether it's it's sort of
inspirations from
nature or whether trying to
to to reverse engineer how humans do it
but i guess i'll leave it there have
there been any biological solutions for
objects yeah for sure yeah i think um
uh
i think especially when it comes to hand
design uh many many hands are actually
biologically inspired and are
anthropomorphic right and i showed like
two examples in this presentation of two
hands that are really looking like human
hands
maybe have one finger only four fingers
instead of five um so there definitely
this but it turns out that
um
sometimes non-biological uh
are actually working much better so for
example one of our partners uh who we're
doing research with
is has actually developed a particular
end effector for a
two-fingered gripper that is more like a
hook and it really uh
it really eases everything suddenly
right so that so there is a value of
also just thinking outside of what we
know um
uh or what we see um so it's and it's
sometimes really hard to decide like oh
is the biological um inspired solution
here
uh actually good or can we think outside
of the box because it's a robot and we
have the ability to design um and so you
know sometimes you want something that
is not biologically inspired but this
idea of exploiting environmental
constraints is actually um
inspired by observing how people
manipulate it so i know you could think
of it as biologically inspired
uh so
staying on this topic because it seems
like we're getting some more interesting
questions around this um
and i'm gonna i'm gonna read the whole
question and i i so i i don't understand
part of it so but can you speak to
modeling the environment with the
minimal spar spatial matrix so basically
can you speak to how a robot can reduce
complexity in the environment to just
the relevant info for the task right how
does a
how can or does a robot deal and maybe
this is beyond the current research deal
with a complex environment and figure
out i i don't need to deal with all this
noise over here i just want to deal with
this right in front of me
yeah oh yeah this is like a very hard
question
um and yeah that's like ongoing an
ongoing research question and there are
many different ways on how to do that
for example there is a biologically
inspired approach that is called
attention um so people are actually also
doing that right like they focus on
parts that are important to the task
that they are doing right now and they
kind of like ignore
even unconsciously like um that uh
things that are not important
and so there are also ways on how to
implement that on a robot so that it for
example visually only pays attention to
things that are somehow salient and pop
out or
that are
probably relevant for the task it's
doing
and
we have
we have done work on this actually on
training um
a model that
is task dependent is paying attention to
certain things in a task dependent way
and as training data we used
[Music]
eye tracking
or we track basically where people are
searching when they are supposed to find
a particular object in an image and
so we just used this eye tracking data
and trained uh a model for for robots
basically on this
another way on how to
have a robot compress all the sensory
information that comes in is by
learning lower dimensional
representation of this very high
dimensional sensory data in the context
of a task so that's actually what we've
done in a work that i haven't presented
here at all
where a robot is also supposed to do a
manipulation task and uh we learn uh
from
you know high dimensional images and
tactile data to compress it into
just like 124 dimensional vector and we
showed that this is good enough for
actually then feeding it into a learned
policy to do the task and so that's
really learned in the context of the
task as well
and
the
somewhat the limitation there i see is
that um
these representations they don't
necessarily then generalize to other
tasks right and so
i think what we haven't yet figured out
is
how to compress information
for
automatically for any kind of task right
so we can do it pretty well for one task
but then that kind of compressed
information doesn't necessarily work
very well for another manipulation task
yeah another interesting research
question
yeah
i think this is is building on that
question is is can you and you
talked about human scanning the
environment can you talk about um
vision-based tactile sensing and
non-vision sensing approaches that and
and what you see in the differences of
those if there are there are
opportunities in one approach of the
other um trade-offs those kinds of
things
yeah so
uh yeah in fact i've been working with
many different kinds of sensing
modalities
and vision or just like rgb like just
color images and video are
very important but i also worked a lot
with just depth images um so where
you can directly perceive 3d structure
of the world and this is in fact very
important for robot decision making
because they are moving in this 3d world
so they really have to understand
how far away something is
where a robot hand is relative to this
object what the shape really of this
object is the three-dimensional shape
and so that's certainly really important
but then what is specifically important
for manipulation is also the sense of
touch and um
that um
is a
like especially once an object is in the
hand or close to the hand it's very
important to use that kind of sense
because there are a lot of occlusions
just by the hand with
of the object and so it's important to
use that other sense that is not
affected by this occlusion
but
it's very different from visual
data
and also
the hardware
um
for uh tactile sensing is actually not
as advanced maybe as cameras or there
are many different solutions unclear
what is the best one and they are not
like good necessarily good
architectures to process this data
so this is also very open space but it's
undoubtedly it's very important for
robot to have that sense of touch but
it's also like another open area that is
very exciting to look at
and another interesting modality uh that
i haven't also not really shown is the
modality of sound so how
um if a robot for example taps on an
object and it makes a sound or maybe
with a tool or something like that
can it infer the material properties
it can turns out and
and if it if it knows that it can
actually maybe adjust its manipulation
strategy because oh it figured out it's
glass so it's more slippery or maybe
it's something rougher uh so it's it's
not as slippery so it can like somehow
grasp it differently so so this is
another uh interesting
uh modality that is actually quite under
explored in in robotics as well
that's right that's uh that's really
interesting that'd be exciting
i i think uh
yeah i
be interesting to see how sound is is it
figures into future robots in terms of
figuring out their their environment um
i i wanted to come back to maybe some of
the some questions around i think it was
your uni grass model and around the um
and
the point clouds so two questions around
that one very specific is if it that
just came in is do you do you see any
applications for
um
if i understand the point clouds were
used to just configure the grippers
themselves did you do you see any
applications for configuring the whole
arm using those models to configure the
whole arm or other parts of the robot
yeah i think
i think i think i see that although i
would say
in that second part uh the robot arm
actually had to be moved in such a way
that none of its parts are colliding
with the environment
um while the hand is actually colliding
with things right so it's a little bit
of a different uh problem or the the
hand and the rest of the arm actually
have slightly different goals one is
wants to get in uh in touch with things
the other one really doesn't want to get
in touch with things so um it's slightly
different so i personally would solve
the problem of what the arm is doing
differently from what the hand is doing
just because we we can model it pretty
well how to avoid collisions with an arm
while what the fine sensory motor
control of fingers is is like a
different sort of problem that we don't
have as good models for as good cost
functions to optimize and so on yeah but
i think you you could do it but i would
i would actually make a different choice
that's interesting and maybe a follow-up
on that is someone that asked why you
need such high resolution on those point
clouds if there are so
few um
states of the uh the small number of
states for the actual gripper
i see
um
i see so i think that maybe refers to
how the gripper is represented although
maybe it's just a two-fingered gripper
and it has really just one degree of
freedom can open and close the fingers
um yeah that's that's true but there are
especially for the object
an object may have a very complex shape
um and
even with just a simple gripper that can
just open and close the fingers there
are still
infinitely many ways to grasp that
complex object and so you want to really
capture especially the shape of the of
the object to match the
shape of the hand uh to it and so that's
why i would say
um
you know you need this point cloud and
maybe you know you can downsample it but
uh i think the shape the complementary
shape of the gripper too in these
different configurations to the object
is actually quite important to capture
yeah that's great um i we're just about
at time here uh so maybe we've got a lot
of really wonderful questions we didn't
get to them all
but thank you all for participating
jeanette is there anything you would
want to add or anything that you're
particularly excited about in terms of
next steps or the course that you'd want
to leave everyone with
uh oh i'm excited about so many
different things that i already
mentioned like oh equipping robots with
the ability to understand language you
know that uh that peop people talking to
them and telling them what to do and
them being able to do these things or
using sound for example um so all of
these different things i'm excited about
and
i'm excited about exploring ideas that
weren't even in my head so in this
course it's like a great opportunity to
explore these so
and thank you very much everyone for
all these great questions that i saw and
we couldn't even get to um answering
yeah
well thank you uh jeanette thank you
everyone who joined us and uh we really
appreciate your time and we hope you
enjoyed the session
you